hi I'm Alex Franco staff reporter from
The Wall Street Journal just completed
our session on currency flexibility and
competitiveness in Asia and in great
discussion when the main issues was will
you know purchases to continue to stay
flexible will we move toward a more
flexible exchange rates or service look
back towards more fixed exchange rate
systems as we see in China and will they
be a bigger influence one of the other
discussions we had was the level of the
Chinese currency and whether it's a
one-way bad weather continued to rise or
whether there are risks that now it's
employed is good stuff rising and one
last discussions we had an intervention
very interesting about Japan's
interventions after its crisis 22 week
in the end and when it's okay when it's
not okay when the markets right where
the markets wrong when it come to curtsy
levels discuss